the second law of thermodynamics tells
us that everything in the universe tends
towards disorder
and in complex systems chaos is the norm
so you'd naturally expect the universe
to be messy
and yet we can observe occasions of
spontaneous
order the synchronization of metronomes
the
perfectly timed orbits of moons the
simultaneous flashes of fireflies
and even the regular beating of your
heart
what puts these things in order in spite
of nature's tendency for
disorder this video was sponsored by
kiwico
more about them at the end of the video
on june 10th 2000 the millennium bridge
a new footbridge across the river thames
in london was
opened to much excitement but as
crowds filled the bridge it began to
wobble back and forth
police started restricting access to the
bridge but that only resulted in long
lines to get on
the wobble was unaffected two days later
the bridge which had cost 18 million
pounds
was fully closed and it wouldn't reopen
for another two years
so what went wrong well it's
long been known that armies should break
step when crossing bridges
this dates back to an accident in 1831
when 74 men from the 60th rifle corps
were marching
across the broughton suspension bridge
in northern england
it collapsed under their synchronized
footsteps
60 men fell into the river 20 of whom
suffered injuries like broken bones or
concussions
luckily no one was killed but after this
the british army ordered all troops to
break step when crossing bridges
now look at the people walking across
the millennium bridge
most of them are walking in step with
each other
but they are not part of an army they're
random members of the public so
why are they walking together and why
couldn't a modern bridge designed for
heavy pedestrian traffic
handle this well to understand it
we have to go back 350 years
in 1656 famous dutch physicist christian
huygens
created the first working pendulum clock
the goal was to help sailors figure out
where they were on the globe
latitude can be judged by measuring the
position of the sun or stars
but for longitude you also need to know
the time at some fixed location
say your home port but clocks at the
time were routinely out by around 15
minutes a day
so they were effectively useless
huegen's pendulum clocks by contrast
were accurate to around 10 to 15 seconds
per day
huygen's plan was to attach his clocks
to a heavy hanging mass on the ship
so they wouldn't get tossed around by
the rolling seas
his plan called for two clocks in case
one stopped or was damaged
but testing out this arrangement while
at home sick in february 1665
he made a remarkable discovery
two of his clocks hung from a wood beam
across some chairs
watching the pendulums sway back and
forth for hours
he noticed after half an hour or so they
would spontaneously synchronize
as one clock swung one way the second
would swing the other way
as one would tick the other would talk
so he tried disturbing the clocks he set
them ticking out of sync
but again within 30 minutes or so they
were back to the same lock
step huygens thought this strange
sympathy of clocks
must have been caused by air currents
between the pendulums
so he placed a large board in between
them but the clocks continued to sync up
it wasn't the air currents
when he separated the clocks the
synchrony would disappear
their times drifting apart but when he
brought them back together
the synchrony returned huygens realized
the two clocks were synchronizing
because they were hung from the same
wood beam
it transferred mechanical vibrations
from one clock to the other
making the two oscillators coupled
huygens was the first to observe this
kind of spontaneous synchronization in
inanimate objects and although he
qualitatively described what was
happening
it was only a few decades ago that
scientists started fleshing out a
rigorous theory
of synchronization
you may have seen this demo where you
put several metronomes on a light wobbly
platform
and start them out of sync
[Music]
it's trickier than people make it look
when you do get it to work though it's
kind of magical
these metronomes don't have exactly the
same natural frequency
and yet they still beat in time to
understand how this works
it's easiest to first consider a couple
metronomes oscillating in
sync with each other when the large
masses accelerate to the left
they push the platform to the right and
when they accelerate to the right
they push the platform to the left so
the center of mass of the system always
stays roughly in the same spot
now if you start another metronome
completely out of sync with the first
two
the motion of the platform gives it a
kick every half swing
speeding it up until it's in time with
the first two
[Music]
this works regardless of the number of
metronomes you have
the platform just goes whichever way the
majority of metronomes are pushing it
we can represent the position of a
metronome pendulum or any other
oscillator
as a point on a circle this shows its
phase
that is what part of the cycle it's in
so you could call the
rightmost point of the pendulum 0
degrees and then the leftmost point is
180 degrees
and as the pendulum oscillates back and
forth the point goes around the circle
the higher the frequency of the
oscillator the faster that point goes
around
so this represents two metronomes with
different frequencies
[Music]
and this represents two metronomes with
the same frequency
but completely out of phase when the
metronomes are synchronized
in phase their dots go around the circle
together
we can use this depiction to illustrate
a mathematical model
for the synchronizing behavior we've
been looking at it's called
the kuramoto model it says the rate each
dot goes around the circle
equals its natural frequency plus
some amount related to how far it is
from all the other dots
now the size of this term is determined
by the coupling strength
i like to think of it actually visually
by thinking about people that are
running around a track
like suppose you're running with your
friend and maybe your friend
is faster than you your friend says you
know come on move it hurry it up
because you're dawdling you're slow
you're falling behind
so if you have enough fortitude and you
know you try hard enough and if the
friend is sympathetic enough to slow
down then the coupling between you is
strong enough to overcome that inherent
difference in your natural running
speeds
but if you're not very good friends or
you know if you can't quite suck it up
to move yourself faster
then the coupling will not be strong
enough to overcome that difference and
one person will start lapping the other
the fireflies of southeast asia are
apparently good enough friends
because they synchronize their flashes
even though each one has its own
particular frequency at which it likes
to flash
they couple to each other strongly
enough so that hundreds
even thousands can flash together in the
same split second
there's a great simulation of this by
nikki case you start with individual
fireflies just
doing their thing and then you can turn
on the interaction between them
now in the kuromoto model this would
mean every firefly has an effect on
every other one
but in this simulation a firefly is only
affected by its neighbors
if it sees a flash close by it nudges
its internal clock forward
a little bit so it'll flash sooner than
it would have otherwise
now what's remarkable about this is even
though the interactions are small and
close range
over time you can see waves traveling
through all the fireflies
and eventually they're all flashing at
once
like you might think if you increase the
coupling you just sort of gradually get
a system more and more synchronized
that's not what happens it's sort of
like the way water doesn't gradually
freeze as you lower the temperature
it's water water water as you're
lowering the temperature and then at a
critical temperature
the molecules suddenly start to change
their state and become solid instead of
liquid
and this is a sort of time rather than
space version of the same thing
they sort of lock their phases in time
once you pass a critical level of
coupling and
at that point the sort of
crystallization in time is the
phenomenon that we call synchronization
[Music]
this is an audience in budapest
applauding after a performance
but what happens next is completely
spontaneous
they're not being instructed by anyone
see if you can spot the phase transition
this phenomenon of synchronization that
we've been talking about one of the
things that i find most appealing about
it
is how universal it is that it occurs at
every scale
of nature from subatomic to cosmic
it uses every communication channel that
nature has ever devised from
gravitational interactions electrical
interactions chemical
mechanical i mean you name it anyway the
two things can influence each other
nature uses that to get things in sync
take our own moon for example we only
ever see one side of it because it
rotates on its axis exactly once
for every time it goes around the earth
we say
it is tidally locked to the earth and
this is a common effect
in our solar system there are 34 moons
that are tidally locked to their planet
the way this happens goes something like
this a moon starts out with its own
rotational frequency
but the gravitational attraction to the
planet is stronger
on the side closer to the planet and so
it distorts the moon into an egg shape
which is greatly exaggerated here as the
moon continues to orbit and rotate on
its axis
those bulges swing out of alignment with
the planet
and so the gravitational force on them
is constantly pulling them back
into alignment and this slows the
rotation of the moon
until it is locked to the planet if the
moon is initially rotating too slowly
this same mechanism can speed it up
until it's locked
there are all kinds of other beautiful
synchronization phenomena in our solar
system the three innermost moons of
jupiter
io europa and ganymede are not only
tidally locked to the planet
they're also in a one two four orbital
resonance with each other
for every time ganymede goes around
jupiter europa goes around
twice and io four times
[Music]
in the 1950s some russian chemists went
looking for
a chemical reaction that would oscillate
like a chemical analog of a pendulum
like could you get something going back
and forth say between blue and orange
over and over again and naively
you might say that's impossible because
there's
principles of thermodynamics which say
that
closed systems just increase their
entropy over time that they're just
going to come to equilibrium
but there's no principle in chemistry or
thermodynamics that says you have to go
monotonically to equilibrium
you are allowed to oscillate and damp
out to equilibrium in an oscillatory way
this is exactly what boris bellows off
and later anatole jabatinskiy discovered
so this reaction is known as the bellows
of zabatinski or
bz reaction i've sped it up because it
can continue for half an hour or more
oscillating between these colors now it
spends more time on the burnt orange
color so i've sped up those sections
more
it's it's very spectacular and it's kind
of shocking to see a chemical reaction
doing these periodic changes in color
like chemicals acting like a clock like
a pendulum
so the stirred reaction has the
advantage that you
really get a sense of the collectivity
of of you know i don't know quadrillions
of molecules avogadro's number of
molecules
all doing the same thing at the same
time on the other hand
if you don't stir if you just put like a
petri dish of the bz reaction
you can see something even more amazing
i think which is that you can see spiral
waves of color or target patterns
expanding
circles of color moving through the
liquid
maybe i should emphasize the liquid
itself is not moving it's not like we're
seeing
ripples on a pond but what's not still
is chemical concentrations
you can see these blue waves in the bz
reaction
that are chemical waves not not water
waves and that will just
propagate and they move at a constant
speed and or they can
look like a spiral that just grows and
grows and spins around
and what's really spooky and uncanny
about this is that the same phenomenon
is seen in the heart
you can see spiral waves of electrical
excitation in a heart
that look exactly like the spiral waves
in chemical
oscillations and chemical waves in the
bz reaction
and this was the sort of thing that
inspired my mentor a guy named art
winfrey
who used chemical reaction waves
to give himself insight into cardiac
arrhythmias
you know you may have heard the most
deadly kind of arrhythmia that the kind
that will kill you really in a matter of
minutes
ventricular arrhythmias ventricular
fibrillation in particular
winfrey's work seeing these rotating
spirals on hearts
as well as in in chemistry led him to a
theory
about what's really causing ventricular
fibrillation
and how could we design for example
better defibrillators
that are gentler that could be a good
outcome of this theory
you know the lack of synchronization in
a fibrillating heart is what causes no
blood to be pumped
and then sudden death ensues so too
little synchronization is obviously a
problem but
too much synchronization can also cause
trouble
remember the wobbly millennium bridge it
was all apparently
down to something called crowd synchrony
was it the people walking in step that
caused it to oscillate
actually kind of the opposite the
millennium bridge
was designed to look like a ribbon of
light so its construction is unique
unlike a typical suspension bridge its
supporting cables
run alongside it stretch taut like
guitar strings
in the civil engineering literature all
designers
know that you do not build a footbridge
with a resonant frequency equal to the
frequency of human walking
so we take about two strides per second
one with your left foot one with your
right foot so everybody who takes civil
engineering
knows if people are gonna walk on the
bridge it better not have a resonant
frequency in the vertical direction of
two hertz
okay everybody knows that including the
people who who built the millennium
bridge
but what they didn't know and what was
new that day is that
half the frequency is also important a
frequency of one cycle a second
which is the frequency with which you
put down say your left foot
half the time you're doing your left
foot so why does that matter
because when you're walking across a
bridge and you put your left foot down
you put a tiny force
sideways on the bridge and normally that
wouldn't matter because people are all
walking
at their own pace they're not
synchronized so they're sideways forces
which are only about a tenth as big as
their downward forces that they impart
on the bridge
that would be negligible and it wouldn't
do anything to the bridge
but if the bridge happens to have a
sideways frequency of one cycle a second
which the millennium bridge it happened
did then people can actually start to
get the bridge moving a little bit
after the bridge was closed engineers
got their colleagues to walk across
it in increasing numbers while they
measured its acceleration
with 50 people on the bridge there was
very little motion
at 100 the vibrations had barely
increased
at 156 there was still
no wobble but with just 10 more people
166 the acceleration
grew dramatically the bridge swayed
just like it had on opening day the
system had undergone
a phase transition if people can get the
bridge moving a little
it turns out people don't like to walk
on a platform that's moving a little bit
sideways
if you've ever been in a train that's
kind of going faster if you stand up in
a row boat
and it starts moving sideways people
spread their legs apart
to try to stabilize themselves and they
will actually start to walk
in step with the sideways motion of the
bridge you can see footage from the bbc
of people doing that
it's spectacular and crazy so
it wasn't people walking in sync that
got the bridge to wobble
it was the wobbling bridge that got
people to walk in sync
and so as the people got in step with
the motion of the bridge
by adopting this weird kind of penguin
gate they ended up
inadvertently pumping more energy into
the bridge and making its motion worse
and and so this was this positive
feedback loop between the motion of the
crowd
causing the bridge to move more which
caused more people to get in step with
the bridge which made more people
you know drive the bridge once the
problem was identified
they could solve it by decreasing the
coupling strength
they installed energy dissipating
dampers all along the bridge
it was a tremendous embarrassment and it
cost several million pounds to repair
the bridge
in science we do reductionism all of our
science courses tell us the way to solve
a problem is to break it into smaller
parts and analyze the parts
and that has been phenomenally
successful for every branch of science
but the great frontier in science today
is what happens when you try to go back
to put the parts together to understand
the whole that's the field of complex
systems
that's why we don't understand the
immune system very well
we don't understand consciousness very
well or the economy
it seems like the whole is more than the
sum of the parts that's the cliche that
has entranced me for my whole
research career i want to understand how
can you figure out the properties of the
whole
given the properties of the parts
hey this video was sponsored by kiwiko
which makes awesome hands-on projects
for kids
and i've actually been using their
subscription crates with my kids for
over a year now so
i wanted to reflect on some of the
things i really enjoy about them
first of all my kids want to do these
projects with me
when a crate arrives they're excited to
crack it open and start making
and you can do exactly that because
everything you need comes right in the
box
now my kids are still pretty young but
kiwi co has eight different subscription
lines targeted at different age groups
all the way down
to newborns when i was filming for this
sponsor segment my four-year-old
completely unprompted
proposed doing an experiment i wonder
what
we could do all we could do was be
met that's a good idea we could try
pushing it and let it go that's a good
idea let's try it
i was so proud that he came up with that
all by himself
and i want him to keep thinking like
this considering the what ifs and asking
bigger questions
a kiwiko crate is like a thought starter
in a box
plus it is time to connect have fun and
be entertained for hours
so if you want to try it out go to
kiwico.com veritasium50 and you'll get
50
off your first month of any crate i'll
put that link down in the description
so i want to thank kiwiko for sponsoring
veritasium and i want to thank you
for watching